so continuing our candidate interviews
today we're going to be speaking with
johnny teague who's a republican running
in texas's 7th congressional district
that includes
uh some of the swanky parts of houston
texas if i understand correctly uh great
great having you on i appreciate it
it's an honor to be with you thank you
and your audience for having me so
there's a number of different ways we
could start this interview and this
might be a weird thing but just as a
sort of gut check i've been asking a lot
of the different republican candidates
we talked to this question
and i i forgive me for such a silly
question but who is the current
president of the united states
current president united states is a
felon named joe biden okay all right
that's a start uh is is he a legitimate
president in the sense that his election
his presence presidency represents the
will of the voters
i think and i always answer this i don't
want to be dodgy but i believe there's
always question in every election going
back uh
benjamin harrison's election there's
always whoever loses is never fully
contented with the election but
following the electoral votes and all
those other things president biden is
our president just like president trump
was elected in 2016 or george bush in
2000. so and
if the baseline is that the loser always
has some questions is there anything
different in 2020 than just the norm of
the loser never really being fully
satisfied as you say
i don't i don't think so i think well i
will say there are some differences one
difference was because of covid we had
drive in or drive up voting
which we never had that before so yeah
there there were some differences with
voting this time okay but your but big
picture you're not saying it's a
dramatically different situation in
terms of the loser being dissatisfied
that they really lost
no i mean 1960 was a was a
crazy election great questions about it
every every election that hillary
clinton greatly questioned the 2016. so
yeah i think you're right all right
about as reasonable an answer as we've
heard i guess all considered
so um okay in in terms of your platform
you know one of the things i noticed is
that a lot of your background
is heavily religiously oriented i mean
you you know you're a pastor you have a
master of divinity and your religious
credentials are certainly very present
when one reads about your background in
terms of the relationship between
religion and civil government
do you you believe that there should be
separation there
i believe that there has been separation
the way our founders intended and the
way the founders intended was that
government never ever interfered with
religion didn't sponsor religion it
didn't
favor one religion over another that was
our founder's intent
but as far as me being a christian
running for congress or a pastor
you know i pay taxes just like an
electrician does just like a rancher
does and i'm a rancher and when our when
our founder said it's to be a government
or really coming back to lincoln the
government of the people for the people
by the people i'm part of the people and
uh as i pay taxes as i'm able to vote
a pastor ought to be able to run for
office just like electrician or a
publisher or a lawyer absolutely now
when you think about your views on any
particular issue and this is really a
very broad philosophical question
you of course
can't separate your religion from your
opinions and so for many folks
their opinion about something like
abortion personally is informed by their
religion which is part of their moral
code without question that that i think
is the case for everybody
do you believe
that those religious views alone
are enough to determine what should be
law in the united states
well let me come back you use the term
religion let me use a different term
world view
not everybody has a religion there's
some more anti-religion there's some who
just are agnostic yeah you could be
absent to religion yeah so so world view
is what we're talking about not religion
my world view is is shaped by my faith
no doubt
but just like someone else's worldview
is shaped by their lack of faith we all
have backgrounds and experiences but
yeah i mean my my sense my belief of
right and wrong is based on two things
god's word and the constitution no
different from john adams who said our
form of government
is only for moral religious people and
it's not adequate for any other so i
kind of hold that same view that john
adams held
um your uh your twitter account is
really interesting now i guess i should
say but do you do you run your own
twitter account or someone else don't i
don't that twitter thing i i guess i
guess uh president trump was a big
twitter fella i'm not a twitter guy i
have a little lady that puts things out
there who volunteers for the campaign
and so i really tried to rein that in
because it's so quick whoever runs your
twitter account
they almost take on the personality of
the candidate when they're not the
candidate the reason i'm glad you're
telling me that because i don't even
know if you know this but on your
twitter account there's a lot of q anon
stuff now just like as a as do are you
have you ever heard the term q anon
before
i haven't and i when you say there's a
lot of q anon i know in 2020
uh the lady who did my uh twitter thing
put out a q a
she there was something that q anon put
out that she liked and shared it i guess
that's what you do with twitter
and man i started getting all kinds of
calls are you with q and i do you
support q and on and i'm like no i don't
at that time i even knew who they were
and so i'm praying that you've only seen
one thing on q a and if you well i've
seen four uh you know so so i mean just
glancing through
i saw a retweet of three women taking
what's called the q anon oath i saw a
retweeted video
uh with a jfk junior conspiracy theory
which is a big q and on thing i saw was
that brother i'm sorry
do you remember the dating on those it
says june although i admit it's not
clear whether it's june of this year or
last year
well i'll tell you what and i'm not
trying to be evasive by any means you
can look at my post on facebook you can
look at my post on my website you'll
never see a dog thing on q and on but if
what you're saying is correct and when
we finish i will make sure to check that
yeah that will i'll shut the twitter
account down okay but so you're you seem
to be clear like q you you have nothing
uh positive to say about q anon and
you're not associated in any way with
that i'm not associated at all and i
thought we'd take care of this in 2020.
uh we have a sweet lady named miss
eileen and miss eileen you know
i'm a guy just running i have about 300
volunteers that work with me nobody's
paid
and so just like i pastor my church i
trust people to do what i expect them to
do and when they don't i have to take
some pretty strong action there you go
so i will shut that puppy down if i find
any q a and stuff and you can check me
in two hours beautiful if there's
anything there it will be gone or the
twitter account will be closed okay fair
let's um let's dig into something policy
oriented just to give our audience a
sense of where you are taxes okay to
pick something that is uh
often um
a hot button issue right now in terms of
the federal income tax brackets and
rates that we have
what's your opinion too high too low
just right not enough brackets too many
brackets
i think we're probably okay right now
with the tax structure
i don't like that we're 33 trillion 32
trillion dollars in debt
i know that we've just hired or we've
set the bill for 87 000 new irs agents
what i'm finding is we are spending
way too much in government and when you
spend way too much in government
you've got to try to
pay for that somehow so what we do is
raise taxes
and i believe our government's got to
spend less
and tax less especially when i look at
uh you know everybody should pay their
fair share and everybody ought to pay
their taxes without cheating yes and
i believe that we you know i drive on
those roads that the taxes pay for i
take advantage of the police department
and their protection that those taxes
pay for so as a christian as a pastor as
a citizen of the united states
i believe we pay
what our taxes are and we don't look for
a way out of it and that's a problem
with people in congress i'm afraid and
that's why i'm for term limits eight
years get the heck out serve the people
and don't be
uh financially
um rewarded for the time you served
because then that removes the whole word
of service but we find a lot of people
in congress
the very ones who are raising taxes and
hiring rs agents are the ones who pay so
few taxes and so i honestly think every
tax return ought to be made public if
you're in public office if you're
elected
that way you see people are living under
the very laws they're making everybody
else but a short answer to your question
forgive me for going along
short answer your question
i think it's probably okay the way it's
set up as long as taxes aren't
continually being raised as long as
we're not finding other ways to raise
more money to cover overspending so to
just go back to the irs agents thing i
couldn't tell from when you mentioned
the hiring of additional irs agents
whether you see that as a good thing or
a bad thing because it seems as though
being so short staffed those additional
irs agents
will actually
bring in more money by by finding people
who are cheating than what they cost
from the analysis i've seen so are you
are you in favor or against the
additional
oh you're against it
and i i think when you look at what
we're paying for 87 000 i'm not saying
we're not short staffed you know we we
need to make sure that we're well
staffed but 87 000 agents you look at
the cost for those 87 000 agents and
then you got to do the math and figure
out
will they really pay for themselves and
if they just pay for themselves
that's not a benefit at all no that's
true but i guess i would question like
the the congressional budget office
nonpartisan does scoring of all of these
proposals they found that it actually
would bring in more revenue than than
than it would cost do you have something
to contradict that
well no i don't because again i'm not in
congress so i don't get uh special
insights into
how they formulated no neither am i but
i'm just saying is there anything we
both have access to all the same things
do you have anything that would point in
a different direction
i don't i mean i'm a mathematician uh
through training but uh i'd have to look
at it but i i honestly believe
that uh we don't need 87 000 irs agents
and i honestly believe that we can we
can be a lot more frugal in what we do
and again
we should never cheat on our taxes we
should pay our taxes in full
in the same light though
we need to not spend beyond what we have
ours our national debt
has eclipsed our gdp
that's just not right we you know johnny
teague in my world
i don't make a lot of money but i can't
spend more than i make
and we have got to apply that i think
government should spend less so we tax
less i think we should not give out as
much money but but as people to earn
uh their living and so i just really
believe and i'll give you an example we
just spent i think 11 million dollars
here in houston to beautify our bus
stops
now i just think
that it's great to beautify our bus
stops sure but 11 million dollars and
let me give you a quick example uh my
people are campaigning for me they put
out my cards throughout the community uh
one one guy which i hate i tell them
don't put these cards on a car that
irritates people it hacks them off don't
put on the car but one guy put in a
lady's windshield well it rained here in
houston and that lady tried to pull it
off her windshield after the rain and
the paper struck to the windshield so
she called me and she said johnny
i'm going to vote for you
you have said in your statements you
think we ought to love care for others
and do right i'm going to see if you're
going to back that up my windshield i
can't get the paper off my windshield i
want you to come to my house this
afternoon and watch my car
i said ma'am i'm so sorry about that
happening if i was free i'd come wash it
but i'll tell you what uh please go get
it washed and i'll pay yeah for the
watch i promise so she uh called me
yesterday
and says uh johnny i got my car washed
it looks wonderful i go great shears now
i got to tell you i'm not able really to
drive it was actually in her in her
front yard she goes so i had to order
one of those mobile car wash companies
to come to my house and wash my car
and i said well i know those are kind of
expensive how much did it cost she said
it was 210 dollars yeah so johnny had to
pay 210 dollars to get a little paper
off the windshield and i asked you the
question
why do you think she was willing to pay
210 dollars well because it was johnny
teague's money now i understand but some
of these analogies i mean you know you
analogized to you can't spend more than
you have so so cun but countries
regularly deficit spend i don't think
deficit spending is necessarily the
issue i mean give me a sense of what
would you cut what do you cut from the
federal budget
well honestly i'd cut um
i'd cut some of the departments
i would cut uh
some of the excessive things that we do
which which one
which ones
which what which departments and which
excessive things that we do which
departments i honestly would probably
cut the department of education not
surprisingly i would cut the
environmental protection agency i would
probably cut the federal reserve
again i'm coming to you again as an
outsider yeah so please know i don't
have full knowledge of of anything yeah
but based you know just like um
you may not have full knowledge on how i
raise my black angus cattle you probably
don't know what i have to do to have my
coastal grow my hay fields
i don't think a lot of the congressmen
would know that because i do that every
day yeah well i'm going to come at you
not be in the know-it-all that's what
i'm actually here to learn from you
brother dave well i would propose johnny
that on department of education
eliminating department of education has
become a popular right-wing uh idea
to damage public schools under the
premise that they are liberal
indoctrination to instead support
religious and so-called patriotic
education i don't like it i think i
think it's a trojan horse and the truth
is that if you eliminate the department
of the epa
this idea that every business is
incentivized to police itself when it
comes to pollution it's been proven
false and without the epa
pollution and as a result all sorts of
disease and cancer as a result of that
pollution would explode those are the
perspectives i would encourage you to
consider
well and i actually disagree with you
and i encourage you i'm not surprised
i mean i mean we can go with what you
say or if you want me to share i'll be
happy to
no i mean it's uh i'm just suggesting
you consider those perspectives yeah
yeah absolutely and may i
say i don't believe that uh
wanting to change our department of
education or remove it isn't some right
wing uh
christian or
biblical pounding thing
you look at how kids are doing right now
in math
for instance and i taught college
algebra
they're doing terrible and mad
look at how they're achieving on these
different metrics whether it be science
or english
they can't even write curse of anymore
where we have seen that writing cursive
forms the connection the brain and the
memory better than just printing
so i mean these are just basic things i
think we're we're teaching kids the
fringe things
which which i think are fine
but i think we're gonna get back to the
basics and so i believe we need to spend
more time teaching math science english
things are really going to help kids uh
function in life and get a job afterward
after they get out of school now with
the epa
i believe firmly
you're right i think that there have
been great errors in the past great uh
crimes against humanity at times that
have really harmed people we see it even
here in houston where companies
sometimes
more worried about the bottom line than
anything but today in a social conscious
in a social media in a moment by moment
news cycle
i believe there's greater policing i
mean there's a reason oil and gas
companies are looking at at wind and
solar and they're looking to clean the
environment uh you see blackrock and
these other investors that are that are
really pressing them
and i'm not a black rock fan but they're
pressing these companies to be more
socially responsible
so you look at oil and gas right now
people are complaining about the price
of gas and i'm one of them
you look at what our government is
saying again you're going to disagree
but i believe that our government has
cut drilling i believe our government
has cut pipelines i believe our
government has made it hard to have a
refinery
and and even i talked to an old
executive the other day and i was an
accountant for shale so i i do have some
oil and gas experience you may say it's
jaded
but an oil and gas guys say johnny
it's more risky
or it's as risky let me be accurate it's
as risky for us to drill in the united
states as it is venezuela and nigeria
and that's because they spend all this
money in r d
they get a well ready to come
and then the government yanks that
license or that permit
and sometimes under the guise of
protecting some species
and yet you look at
wind and solar and the damage it does to
species as well i think we've got to
care for our environment but anyway i
think that regulations are raising
prices uh i think they're harming us i'm
a farmer a race uh hey
fertilizer is
three times more this year than it was
last year uh and i know part of that's
the russia invasion of the ukraine but
we're also being told what fertilizer we
can use what we shouldn't use uh then
we're telling food uh shortages are
going to occur
so i just think that we've got
government does a good job but sometimes
you overreach just like i do well if i
may johnny that was the equivalent of an
ink blot of different things going
between fertilizer prices wind power
species and i don't think it will shock
you that
i disagree with basically everything you
just said but that's uh
going to have to be for a different
conversation since we have uh we our
time today has elapsed um it's an
interesting race that you're running in
the seventh congressional district we've
been speaking with republican johnny
teague
let's see how things go in november and
then we'll uh we'll reconvene from there
and let me say one thing i'm thankful
for you and i'm thankful that we
disagree thank you and i do want to
listen and david i'm not always right in
fact i'm often wrong true but i do want
to learn and and thank you for being so
gracious to me
regardless of where you stand on the
issues i'm thankful we live in a country
where we can be free
and and we can still be brothers and
americans
and and have vast differences on the
issues i appreciate your time thank you